foreign
[Music]
she'll receive certificates that will
attest to the fact that you have
gotten these new skills and can
demonstrate them Purdue will stand
behind that and simply almost stand
behind that and for some of the skills
IBM will stand behind that because
program is got content and instruction
modules from IBM as well
over the time the course of the eight
months you'll be doing more than 14
different projects and Labs we'll
make available master classes from
Purdue instructors and faculty from IBM
instructors you'll have access to
hackathons and EMA sessions
um
I'm sorry Capstone project
which will cover in more detail allows
you to create
a
experience an example that you can take
with you to show off all of the skills
you've gained in the program
and then simply learn also provides job
assistance program
you'll have access to the Purdue alumni
association as well so career Care
Program Capstone project we have
services available for that as well
talk about Purdue University Purdue
University established over 150 years
ago
one of the first land grant universities
where
American states decided that to make
available higher education opportunities
for their citizens
this is one of the
this is the first one in Indiana I
believe but it has gained an
international reputation as one of the
leading uh public universities in the
United States
and it's produced Nobel Prize winners
and winners of other academic prizes
um
so it's recognized worldwide and it's
definitely got a reputation that will
gain attention if you have that praise
Purdue University on your CV or resume
okay
we also as I mentioned
Incorporated IBM into this program
so that there are some courses that are
actually IBM curriculum taught in a
standard way and you get therefore the
completion certificates from IBM for
those particular parts of the program
which are over and above the
certificates issued I simply learned
that in Purdue
plus the access to the ask me anything
sessions to the
hackathons
and the master classes for my VM people
so this is really good exposure into
folks from industry
now I'll mention the career assist
service which is available I know we
have a worldwide audience with the
number of different countries as I
mentioned just before we started uh you
were all generous to share where you're
from
um
this is available specifically in India
and the United States so I apologize for
not not being available in other
countries at present but
this part of the program
extends for six months after you earn
your certificate
and it's meant to help you in your job
search it's not a placement service or
job guarantee service but it's a set of
services that will help you focus your
job search and sharpen your skills so
that you increase your chances of
finding employment and it includes
webinars that simply run runs on a
regular basis
for career development it includes the
projects that you do in the program that
become your portfolio of real world
experience to show off during your job
interviews and it includes some formal
job assist services in the US through
Talent Inc and in India through IIM jobs
pardon me um
one of the components is the job portal
in each of those uh
regions
you have access to an exclusive job
portal resume rabbit in the US IIM jobs
in India
that allows you to search their employer
networks
um
do the job search in a discrete and
private way so that your resume isn't
Exposed on dice or indeed or that type
of thing if you want to do your job
search in the private manner
the other two components of the of the
services available in both of those Geo
regions is
uh their resume review and rewrite which
is extremely important today's day and
age
your resume goes to an automated
tracking system and an AI bot before it
ever goes to a human being so
having a resume that's written in a way
that the bot can understand content your
experience your skills and match them
with the job requirements a job
description
very important because you want the
process to filter you into the job
search and not out of it
once you get filtered through that first
step
your resume still has to be appealing to
the human eye because it will land on
someone's desk or screen
and so being able to create a resume
that satisfies both the AI requirement
the human appeal requirement is a kind
of art form that this will help with
you'll have a professional writer
helping you craft your resume in that
way you'll also have
the interview service and what this will
do is give you live practice with you a
human interview practice
a partner who will help you through the
different styles of interviews because
as probably are aware
in any job search you have to go through
several different layers of interviews
starting from the phone screen with a
HR person or recruiter to the technical
interview with your potential peers and
supervisor who'll be very interested in
your technical skills and your ability
to do the work and then to the
management compatibility interview
where people will be concerned with
your fit with corporate culture your
work ethic and
your ability to be a good team player
and good teammate each of those resumes
has a different flavor each of them
requires a little bit of different skill
set from you and being able to practice
each of those is a really valuable
service
mentioned we have a set of
webinars that we do on an ongoing basis
some of them include one hour short
lessons drawn from our different
programs in different skill areas
overviews of the
technology sector so for example you
might see one on
what data analytics Trends are are
coming in the coming year you might hear
about new technologies
see some that are about how to do your
job search and how the organization
and then others on programs soft skills
in different skill areas make overviews
of the your careers flow technology
sector all of those are free they're
available to you uh definitely a
lifelong basis so that's part of the
service
and at this point I'd like to ask a
question of audience this is about
um eligibility and prerequisites you do
have to have a bachelor's degree
uh discipline it can be any liberal arts
technical engineering
any discipline but you must have uh 50
marks which is I believe a GP of 2.0 or
better
and you need to come from you don't need
to come from any particular background
you can have programming experience but
if you don't that's fine you also don't
have to have work experience although
it's always helpful it is not mandatory
for this program question I have for you
is how much experience do you have
this would be experience in the formal
workplace
regardless of the field or the type of
work
I'll leave this open for another
10 seconds
close this in
four three
two
one
now share the results
about a quarter of our audience or folks
who are still working on their degrees
and then
the rest of you have varying levels of
experience including a third of the
audience which has more than five years
of experience
um so this is
a program that will be suitable for
pretty much
the bulk of our audience
let me
now move on to how this program prepares
you and we'll discuss
the curriculum before on the tendra
shares with you uh a demonstration of
how the learning environment works
the I'm I'm a tendra if you were ready
I'd like you to maybe jump in as I'm
going through this curriculum correct me
if I'm dealing with anything that's um
uh in the induction session is the first
module that teaches people how to use
the learning management system
introduces them to the overall
curriculum where you'll find your
resources how you'll get enrolled in
each class how you get into your live
classes that you'd find recorded
information and other
tools how to use the programming labs
and all of the the things that you might
have in a freshman orientation type of
class
once you finish that you can move into
your first formal classes which
module is analytics Foundation what is
data analytics what are the basic
principles that uh
lie underneath it and
from that you can then move into
programming
leading to Python Programming training
of IBM provides part of this training
this gives you the background in
programming if you if you hadn't come in
with it already
and it relates it to two data analytics
specifically you'll move into our
programming next R being a language that
is uh
designed for data science and data
manipulation and once you have that
foundation of the programming skills in
R you'll move into applying those in
data science
and
last module before the Capstone project
is using Tableau for visualization
for communicating your insights in a way
that it's accessible to laypeople and
managers and end users
and then the last module is a Capstone
project
which will describe a little bit more
detail but it's a three to four week
effort where you pick a challenge and
then you develop Your solution to that
challenge under the mentorship of an
instructor
and that becomes not only the basis for
evaluating your skill success in the
program but also a piece of practical
experience that you can take with you
and show off
potential employers
and along the way
you can take any or all of the electives
can take a module on power bi which is a
another
tool from Microsoft you can move
going to the introduction to artificial
intelligence if you want to go deeper
toward the data science areas and find
out about some of the new technologies
that are important in analytics and you
can take the master classes from both
Purdue instructors as well as from IBM
all the electives are all at no extra
cost
they're available to you based on your
time availability and your level of
Interest so you can take as many or as
few as you like
cork horses in the staircase there are
the ones that you have to complete to
get your certificate
um is there anything I'm a tender that I
missed here
I'm feeling a stewardia covered
everything in detail okay
um and maybe you can tell us about how
the
um various tools here get used in the
courses
um so that people can end up with uh
demonstrable experience with them
sure
so the entire field data science or data
analytics that we have been talking
about we are discussing about handling
data managing it and then analyzing it
so when you talk about tools so these
tools be it python beat R they come with
with tons of libraries that needs to be
understood before you can analyze the
data with them so what we cover here is
we start with the very basics of any any
of the platform you talk about beat
python beat r or even for that matter
stable or power bi that we are dealing
for for business intelligence so these
tools will be taught uh from from very
Basics and then we will build it upon on
that and these libraries which have been
mentioned over here say pandas which is
an excellent library for data
manipulation which is a must-have
Library when you talk about python will
be dealt in detail we'll also discuss
about numpy which is for numerical
pythons when you want to analyze some
data aggregate it or transform it we can
think of numpy scipy is for scientific
computation so in some of the areas you
might have very specific requirements
you might be working with some some
signal data so signal processing you
want to do or probably you have some
really uh detailed statistical analysis
required so sci-fi comes very handy
similarly for machine learning you have
psychic learn a skill learn as well as a
library so these are the these are the
libraries that you have to learn these
are the tools that you should you should
know for sure and we are actually
bundling them into a single unit and we
are teaching you that we are starting
from basics of python moving to pandas
numpy same thing goes for r as well and
uh and and when we talk about business
intelligence which which comes from
which was that that's where we talk
about descriptive analytics or probably
even when you have done some predictions
or you have done some analysis you want
to present to the end user uh so you you
want to use some some power bi or some
tablet on on that so that's where we are
dealing with that as well and and Excel
is something which is an excellent tool
in terms of uh working with the data to
start with so we have we are touching
base with that as well so this is the
other libraries these are the twos these
are the platforms you you will be
learning at this particular program and
we have kept in mind the entire Project
Life Cycle of data science or data
analytics how it moves keeping that in
mind we have uh Incorporated these tools
and and libraries
thank you Alexandra yeah
one thing to also know about this is
that
these will be used in the different
projects that you'll be doing so you
won't
um only get an academic overview of what
tool is and what the instructions are
for using it but you'll you'll be
required to use them in your projects
and therefore at the end of the program
you will be able to claim um expertise
and skill in each of these areas
um before we go to the live demo I just
want to say one more thing about the
Capstone we talk about
um choosing a problem yet to choose a
problem that's aligned to or opposed as
the kind of problem that somebody would
give to you in your job as a data
analyst
and you design and Implement Your
solution again
turn to your instructor and to make sure
that not following any rabbit holes or
dead ends but uh you are the one
responsible for doing the project
it'll be judged on
your accomplishment so it's something
that you can show off as your practical
experience
so now I'm going to ask amitendra to
share his screen and take us through
a tour of the learning management system
you'll be using a different program from
Purdue
um to illustrate this but the methods
and the use of the system are identical
I'm a tender if you would
no
so this is how our LMS look like once
you log into your system
and once you log in you get your course
listed and uh the uh the course that
you're talking about is data analytics
so that will be listed and you you have
an option of going to your program so
click on that and it moves to the
courses that are that that are part of
your program so you will have starting
from induction and then going to to
fundamentals of programming and all and
then any curves that we are talking
about which is part of your entire
curriculum like if I say say first
suppose I move to one of the program so
here is the thing that we have done for
you we have curated uh everything at one
place in a sense that we have a learning
track over here which will help you with
all the topics that will be covered and
you get videos over there which is for
yourself learning if you want and uh
over over here itself you get live
classes option if you see here so once
you log in you have an option of
finishing some of the self-learning
video so that you can you can gain some
understanding before going to the live
class then you have an option of over
here itself click on this and you can
join the live class whenever it is
scheduled
you also get over here a practice lab so
once you click on the practice lab
a lab will be started for you where you
can do all the assignments or you can do
the practice along with the trainer like
in the live classes when we when we talk
about we we explain you a concept and
after explaining a concept we we give
you a problem statement that this is the
data which has been given to us and this
is a problem statement and let's solve
it together so when trainer is teaching
you any concept they will provide you
some data to implement that concept and
then gain some understanding out of the
data or probably sometimes do some
predictive models all that you will be
simultaneously doing with with the with
the trainer and not only that once we
have finished the entire assignment or
an entire practice which is there if you
want then trainer can share their
notebook also with you that Pro that
option is also provided then over here
you see you have an option of reference
material at the same place you can
download all the ppts or any study
material that trainer is using you can
also download from here and also in a
classroom every section will have
will have a Hands-On
exercise it could be an exercise it
could be a small assessment or I
wouldn't say assessment it could be a
case study that you're solving so all
that data set you can download in
advance keep it with you and this data
set is actually given module wise it
will say lesson one these are the data
set we'll be using lesson two these are
the ones that we'll be using so you can
download that entirely and keep it with
you every section of of the course which
is there will have its own case study
that you need to solve to gain
understanding what you have learned in
the classroom and then end of the entire
section that we are teaching the entire
course you will have assessment this is
an individual assessment for that
particular course that we are talking
about which is part of the curriculum so
you might have five six courses part of
your curriculum each one will have their
own assessment so when you go to
assessment over here you will have
couple of case study here which you need
to solve in your lab and then you need
to submit you will also have a test
and then once you finish your assessment
and and finish your test your
certificate will be unlocked over here
in addition to that you also have this
option of connecting to your peers
through a community that we provide and
every every batch will have a different
Community Link so so you can interact
with each other you can interact with
the trainers over there and then you can
create your own notes also if you want
while doing this session virtually like
a notepad
and if suppose you get stuck somewhere
some problem you are facing probably
with the lab or you are having some
technical issues we have a help option
available over here just raise a ticket
and help will be on its way so that's
what we are getting over here bear in
mind all these programs that we are we
are talking about over here will be
entirely Hands-On so not only the
trainers will teach you the concept they
will tell you what's a mathematical
intuition behind a concept and then
eventually how python or how R is coming
into the picture to implement that
concept on the data and that would be
done in practice lab so at one place you
get everything you didn't have to
actually switch to some other platform
in a sense that you might have your your
assessment tab over here but the lab is
somewhere else it doesn't happen that
way in a single place you will have
everything
Incorporated and you can and start
working on it also if you don't want to
if you don't want to install anything on
your system that's perfectly fine
because we are giving you a Virtual Lab
so this is how the lab works and Stuart
if you want to add something over here
feel free to do that
um if you would take us back to the um
the home screen that shows the overall
curriculum there you go and explain how
somebody can keep track of their
progress through the program this way
so what happens over here the the good
thing is that the entire program
curriculum will be listed over here like
this program talks about the first
section is course one is that it will be
just an induction program then you have
course two which is python for data
science and if you see here it shows
that I have completed the first 100
percent but the second one stands at 11
percent so it also gives you
understanding where do you stand in
terms of the entire program and it will
it will give you this tracking part over
here and as we progress each one will be
completed in detail so you'll have your
live classes some self-learning videos
you will have your labs and each each
course that we talk about as I mentioned
will have its own assessment once you
finish that once you unlock your
uh certificate you can move to the next
one and then
same procedure will follow there as well
and this is how the entire program this
particular program is which is which is
starting from from python for data
science and then going till your last
Capstone that we are talking about
that's how it moves actually helps you
in terms of understanding that where do
you stand in the entire program what all
has been covered and what is spending
and also gives you understanding that
what will be the next course so you'll
be ready for that so this is how it
comes
much for that and thank you for that
overview
so I'll move back on to the
other process here
you've got to look at the how to manage
your curriculum and and do the live
classes
uh do the tests and assessments and
projects including the Capstone project
as the last course in your series uh
keeping track of your progress unlocking
the certificates along the way and the
support tools all of that is on that one
platform
now again this is a Purdue University
program so uh Dr Wolf
does the
overview of the or oversight of the
curriculum and the delivery in keeps
simply an accountable for delivering
this program to Purdue University's
standards
so
this is why a certificate comes from
Purdue University
I'm going to share with you the
upskilling journey
of one of our
people who completed this and the
program was called postgraduate program
back then it's a professional
certificate program now same curriculum
I had a roller coaster life switching
jobs businesses and pandemic was of no
excuse for me but after finishing my
course last year and making myself a new
career in data analytics getting myself
a new job I really felt calm and which
I'm grateful for last two years was very
tough for me just like many of us but
I've decided to utilize the time in a
productive way and what can be more
productive than self-improvement and
learning hi this is asper and I live in
Chennai I'm an aeronautical engineer by
education but a data analyst by
profession I did a postgraduate program
in data analytics from Simply learn with
Purdue University after finishing my
course within two months I got placed as
a data analyst with Oxford International
while I took this course in order to
improve my business and trading skills
my journey took a turn completely after
completing this course after graduating
in 2017 I moved to a non-technical role
with Jet Airways as an aviation security
officer then I started my clothing
business in 2019 but again I was hit in
roadblock after my clothing business
went to a domino during the pandemic I
started a new business on construction
materials where I got the chance to work
with multiple clients all over India and
that is where I've realized that data is
very much Essential for business
after comparing the course with other
platforms I felt that the course offered
by simply learn has got the best content
after reading all the reviews and videos
from other Learners which gave me the
confidence to actually apply for it as I
was new to data analysis the trainers
were helping me to understand various
topics along with the self-paced
recorded videos were of great help in
clearing all my doubts I always had a
keen interest in share market and crypto
trading to understand this better I
wanted to study Python and to better my
analysis my knowledge of python and
predictive analysis has gone from
strength to strength throughout this
course now I can say I'm doing my
trading with better analysis and with a
minimum loss this certification not
alone improved my resume it also gave me
a Cutting Edge from other candidates I
think it doesn't matter where you come
from what your education background is
or what your fears are as long as you're
headed in your right direction
I always believe there should never be
an ending to learning
[Music]
all right so you're
from one learner here's another
learner's experience and
I'll just leave this up for a second in
case you want to take a look at some of
the
highlights
but this gives you an idea of how the
program
spans your skills gets you into a new
area
takes you from a background
or as far talked about being a
Aviation engineer his background
sahaj here had no data science or coding
experience so this is really an
illustration of how you can come in from
any background succeed in this program
based on everything that Anna tendra
shared with you and that I shared with
you so far
are you interested
in enrolling in this program
I'll leave this open for just about
another 15 seconds because it's a yes or
no question
please get your answers in
and
close the question in five four three
two one
so just under ninety percent of the
folks in our audience today
are interested
rolling which is fantastic I will now
share with you the enrollment steps
so
first thing to do is to email us at ask
us at simplylearn.net I'm going to put
that email address into the chat box for
everyone
what that will do is put you in touch
with the learning consultant who will be
able to
take you through the application process
the main part of the application process
is verifying your academic background to
verify that you have the required
bachelor's degree
and there may be a small assessment test
to talk about
how your aptitude for
uh area
give me a moment I'm going to be kick
Zoom for a second there's a little
technical glitch I'll be right back
okay uh sorry about that it uh Zoom does
that occasionally and I will go back to
the presentation here
so as I mentioned you will go through
this process
um
there may be an assessment test of your
skills and aptitude but that's not a
factor in filtering you out uh it just
won't just want to make sure that you
have the uh ability in the the
commitment to complete the program
successfully
and the next induction
start
on the 18th of April
classes start right after that on the
22nd of April so we ask you to get
started quickly
um and I'll tell you why in a second the
price for the program
us is 299 dollars
it can be financed over time at 264 a
month in equal installments uh in India
the price is one lock eighty four
thousand nine hundred ninety nine rupee
which can be financed at 61.41
uh equal monthly installments
and
the reason we say act now is
the cohort sizes are limited because
this relies on live instructor training
class sizes can't be more than 25 to 30
people
for the instructors to be able to give
attention to each learner
and so uh if you want to get into this
batch you want to get your place
reserved right away
uh I'm going to ask that question now
and the question is how soon would you
like to be enrolled in this program
is something you'd like to do for that
April batch is it something you want to
do maybe in May or June
or something farther down the road
we always say of course that if it's
something that's going to improve your
life and your
career it's always worth doing sooner
than later
I will close the poll in three seconds
get your answers in two one
and
here's the result
fifty percent of our audience wants to
get involved either in April or perhaps
May June and for those of you who are
looking further down the road do contact
us and ask us at simply.net and and we
will keep you informed about future
batches of the program future cohorts
who will also um be able to answer any
questions you may have about the program
so
this point I'm going to go ahead and
take questions for amateendra and me
and
let me go to our q a so quite a few
questions in our queue
extra
momentarily here hold on
there we go
my webcam sometimes gets in the way of
me seeing things
um
apologize for those of you who have
asked us to talk
to explain in Hindi language we
do everything
in our instructions and our webinars in
English
were the broadest possible audience so I
apologize I apologize for that but um
we have a question can a data analytics
help in the startup world I'm attendra
what would you say to that
uh startup these days have understood
that how important the the value of data
is so a startup basically when they have
to take they have to make a lot of the
Season day in day out which will require
probably investing money and some
opportunity or probably hiring somebody
so they want to make sure that every
penny that they are investing is is
worth and and that that way that's where
some some research based on the data
comes into the picture that's one part
second could be that probably they kind
of want to come up with a come up with a
better product better services so again
understanding what people are looking
and how how they can solve a problem
will be very important and that's where
data analytics is coming into the
picture okay
um we have a question from Kieran who
asks what is the difference between the
data analytics role and the data
scientists role
okay so data anal analytics if you talk
about in general is a branch of data
science which is looking to solve very
specific problems data science on the
other hand is a more broader uh
umbrella term that we used where we we
talk about in general that what all is
happening in the data let's find out and
then let's see how it can be mapped to
to uh to a business problem or probably
how it can be used in the business
decisions on the other hand data
analytics is is more of a very specific
problem we are solving like probably we
have a very high attrition rate in the
company and we want to understand what
could be the factors so data analysis is
coming into the picture so the core will
remain same the the requirement in a
sense that basics of of analysis should
be should be understood should be should
be should be learned like some
statistical models some some basics of
Statistics some inferential statistics
has to be learned and you should know
some programming tools as well so that
core will remain same whether you're
moving to data analyst or or data
scientists role but data scientists will
become more broader role you have to
have understanding of not only from from
algorithm perspective but also from on a
broad level how stakeholders are
actually coming into the picture so all
that you have to understand
thank you
um
are the classes daily or what's the
class schedule for the live instruction
this would be a weekly on a weekly basis
over the weekend it would be conducted
so every weekend four hours Saturday for
our Sunday you have to dedicate and
generally what happens two days on the
on the weekend we train and then we give
some exercises which you can which you
can learn which you can do over the
weekdays that's what that's how it goes
um note that you should plan ahead to
have your weekends available for this
program if you miss a class it will be
recorded and you can catch up on it but
there will be requirements in each of
the courses for how many of the live
classes you must attend so I'll always
plan ahead and we recognize that you
can't have every single weekend
available for instruction but
should probably come into the program
thinking kind of along those lines
um
the other question anonymous question is
data access and transfer can you talk
about some of the issues in access to
and transfer of data and I don't know if
they met in general or in specific uh
relationship to this program but if you
could talk first about how people access
the data that they use in the exercises
and then
if you're talking from from our LMS
perspective then the data sets are
available on the LMS and that is shared
and those data sets are are very very
vast and and they have huge huge uh
reach in terms of industry and and
verticals and for every course there
will be different set of data set that
will be provided to you so that you get
Hands-On on on different kind of problem
and also different kind of data
um
one of our attendees has a long
experience more than 10 years as a
senior test automation engineer
and if he
he or she uses this program to
qualify in data analytics
would they be able to expect to move
into a
relatively senior position or would they
have to start at an entry level in data
analysis
uh not really at the entry level in a
sense that it depends on their job role
also currently what they are doing this
is what's happening most of the job role
that we had earlier specifically tied up
for for only some some I.T software
engineer has has been actually moved to
machine learning also as ml Ops have
been picked up like anything over the
period of time so these jobs which we
thought is only only for for probably a
product development or application
development have actually been been
moved to data science and data analytics
also so those experience will not be
gone will not be going in vain that will
be counted because you have understood
how to create any application testing
you're talking about so you'll be doing
some kind of deployment testing probably
model testing so so you have to you have
to be building on what you have done
already and how you can actually map
that to to data science so probably need
little more clarity in terms of what
exactly is doing yeah it's generally
true in in a all backgrounds are all
fields that
the domain knowledge that you bring with
you from your previous experience if
you're pivoting into a technical role
like data analytics the domain knowledge
is very valuable and your ability that's
often what
what you're being hired for is your
ability to to combine your domain
knowledge with the new set of skills so
um we had a question here what's the
handshake between a data analyst and a
data scientist at what point do the data
scientists hand off
the the tools that they develop
data analytics and vice versa
different companies will have a
different take on that generally data
scientists is a broader job role that we
talk about and as I mentioned different
companies have different take on that
but what is the point if you're talking
about I would say that uh
with experience you will move from data
analysts to data scientist job role
that's how it will go okay
[Music]
or Python and R enough to be a data
analyst you have to learn other
tools or
languages especially in visualization
uh to to handle the entire Project Life
Cycle that we talk about in general uh
python would be sufficient in terms of
python or R for that matter in terms of
data acquisition you can use these tools
and even for model building or
deployment we use the same tools but
probably what you can think of as like
uh when you talk about data
visualization in particular we are
talking about something that can be put
across as a dashboard to the end user
and their python or R will not be very
handy because you need interactive
reports so probably a bi tool will also
be very handy and that's a reason we are
offering you Tableau and power bi as
well so basically we are covering the
entire ecosystem this is sufficient to
work in data as a data analyst yeah
thank you yeah the tablet module
the the issue as as I mentioned at the
outset data is only useful if you can
draw insights from it
and similarly the insights are only
useful if you can communicate them to
the people who need to use them that's
one of their main reasons why we offer a
tableau course within this program so
that you can turn those insights into
visualizations and other Communications
to the end users
um
talked about the enrollment deadline
the April cohort
uh
and
let me go through here ah
shadonna asks is this only available in
uh Indian U.S for our programs let me
clarify that the program is available to
you worldwide and in order to find out
the pricing I'll be sharing with you the
URL for our course page so that you can
see what your local price for the
program is the part that is specific to
the US and India is the um job assist
service so if you are in the Caribbean
country and complete the program it's
very valuable to you but we won't be
able to give you the uh
post program
interview prep resume rewrite that type
of thing so that's the part that that is
not included but the rest of the program
and all of its
skills transfer and benefits certif
certificates experience are all
available worldwide
I hope I didn't
um
misspeak earlier
uh is statistics important in data
analysis
and do you have to go beyond a basic
understanding of statistics
well offlet I see people are actually
kind of not focusing on the statistics
and being a statistician really doesn't
look nice but I want to tell you one
thing that status is pretty important
and if you're covering basic statuses
just spend some more time and finish the
little Advanced part of it as well then
only you can call yourself as a data
scientist once you finish machine
learning and everything so data
scientist is somebody who probably
understand entirety of what what
statistics does how machine learning
fits in and how probably deep learning
also coming into the picture so all
these things you have to understand then
only you can call yourself data
scientists statistics is very important
uh you might skip for someone or the
other analysis but eventually you will
come up with something where you have to
deal with it so I'm saying when you're
dealing with Basics finish the advanced
part as well
the question about
other libraries like matplot live and
Seaborn and those would be for different
courses
know that map live is part of some of
our data science and AIML programs
rather than the data analytics program
is that correct
ly uh the Python program that we do so
all the programs which is based on
python that's where it will be dealt
with yeah okay
um
similar question to earlier someone who
has experience in medical coding and it
wants to switch data science will they
be considered a fresher or experienced
and again as Mr Senator said
it depends on where you're going to look
for your your new job and whether your
domain experience data coding uh is part
of the experience that they'll be
looking at so
we'll be getting a recording of This
webinar we will send out a follow-on
email after this webinar with a link to
the recording
um
does the University provide testimonials
not specifically
testimonials uh the certificate access
their testimonial or their their
Testament that they
stand behind your skills as you learn
them
um
yeah uh we have several questions on
costs and you'll be able to take a look
at that on the the website especially
localized to your area so
ask you to do that
um
how long does it take it's an
eight-month program
and
are there scholarship or sponsorship
opportunities you would contact us at
ask us at simplylearn.net to find out
about the uh any of those types of
things
um
is there in-person learning
are are in-person learning is virtual
in-person learning on the LMS so you are
learning
in real time face to face with
instructors like amazonra
um you don't have to spend any money on
travel to get to
the training site so that's an advantage
for you
um
if you uh question if I only want to
stuff it a study specific programming
languages like python R SQL
how do I go about that simply learn
offers other training courses and when I
give you the URL you'll be able to look
at some of those so if you want to take
a specific skill set look at uh learning
that you can find some of those on our
simply learned website this program
takes a whole
spectrum of skills around data analytics
build them into a step-by-step
program that gives you that whole set of
skills
it's a program available for residents
in Africa take a look at the website yes
it is
and matter of fact we have
a great number of students in various
parts of Africa
um
I don't know if I misunderstood for
someone to join you must have a
bachelor's degree Jonathan that's that
is correct you do have to have a
bachelor's degree to be eligible for
this program
uh there are programs between simply
learn partnered with Caltech and Purdue
University what is the difference
between the two programs the programs
are of similar quality
depends on whether for example
who are closer to Caltech in the world
or uh if you prefer
if you have a preference between the two
organizations
both of them are excellent
the quality of instruction is excellent
uh
can someone who doesn't have knowledge
of I.T become a data analyst and
Pretender is that is that possible
sorry I didn't get to you can someone
who doesn't have any knowledge of I.T
become a data analyst
yes you can because
I can tell you I I know a couple of
people whom we have trained they did not
have any understanding of IIT but you
have to pick up the programming language
will be initial little difficult for you
in a sense that you have never done it
but having said that it doesn't mean you
cannot become a data analyst or data
scientist you have to start uh with with
the basics you have to work hard and yes
you can become a detail data scientist
uh and how is data analytics vital in
the NGO sector the non-government
non-governmental organizations
or ngos like they work with people
generally and they capture a lot of data
points in fact a lot of uh deep ground
level understanding that they they
gather is is is basically helpful in in
in in in a variety of ways in a sense it
helps government it helps societies to
to develop certain policies and all so
I'm saying that ngos again depends which
NG you're working with they must be
capturing data sets they much they must
be working with their data and
eventually you want to analyze that you
want to project something you want to
understand what's happening with with
different ground level people probably
or probably certain processes so this
will be very helpful I'm just not very
sure that that whether it will be a very
lucrative offer or not but it is helpful
um someone asked if you need to do an
MBA after doing this course and the two
things are kind of uh separate in that
this is a set of technical skills that
qualify you to do data analytics
extremely helpful if you are going to go
on to do an MBA and work in general
business management or in deeper into
some aspect of business
but um
this is not an MBA program by any
and
how many total attendees do we have
today I don't know if the zoom didn't
show you that but we have
uh last I looked we had over 400
um
and
I think because we're running out of
time I just want to take
um
there's one interesting question I'll
take at the end here which is
um
how do you handle the combinations
between different softwares how do you
do the handoff
and will they be training and how to do
that for example so taking from the
analytics and passing that information
into Tableau we covered those interfaces
well we do that we have to give those
ideas that this is what we have done and
this is what the data was this is how we
have worked upon that it's the kind of
analysis we have done it and eventually
uh that some some cases what will happen
those insights are are constant flow
which needs to be fitted fed into to the
stakeholder so so you need to create
some kind of a dashboard where the the
analysis and sites are kept going in and
then stakeholders can watch it on a
daily basis and then can take some some
kind of decision on top of it so yes
that part will be dealt with where you
have you will be taught how to how to
uh connect our machine learning pipeline
kind of stuff or probably a data set to
to tablet or power bi in that case thank
you all right and I apologize to anyone
whose questions we weren't able to cover
but we are
a bit over time so I'm going to ask a
question of the audience
and I'm going to share with you as we're
doing this question I'll also be sharing
with you the uh
web page URL where you can see the
pricing for your local environment
um let me start this poll
and
if you would like to get a
proof of attendance for this session
tonight today uh answer yes to this
question as well but otherwise answer
yes if you would like us to reach out to
you and help you with answers to
questions and also uh
help with enrollment so I'm going to let
this run while I go to the chat
and I am going to put in
our
URL for the
web page for this program
so that's
that's in the chat and I'm going to end
the poll now
about 50 50.
and that's great so for those of you who
answered yes we will be reaching out to
you and I will also be sending you a
proof of attendance for
this particular webinar we just
completed
and
so this is a time for us to think thank
you to everyone for being here the QR
code will also take you to our webpage
if you want to use that
do
contact us and ask us at simplylearn.net
want to thank amitendra for being for
very generous with his time and his
knowledge today expertise and thank you
again I'm attendra
thanks is to it
and I want to thank everyone who joined
us for this webinar really appreciate
that and we hope we can welcome you into
the Learning Community with Purdue
University
and simply learn
so that concludes our webinar
have a great rest of your evening or day
or wherever you are